Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Did you know that our Sunday Times bestselling book, The Rest is History Returns, is now out in paperback. From finding out who British history's biggest lad was, to tracing the admittedly hazy ancient origins of Raiders of the Lost Ark, it's filled cover to cover with more curious historical moments than you can crack a lasso at.
感谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你知道吗，我们《星期日泰晤士报》的畅销书《The Rest is History Returns》现在已经推出平装版了。从探究英国历史上最著名的风流人物，到追溯《夺宝奇兵》中那些公认扑朔迷离的远古起源，书中随处可见各种妙趣横生的历史瞬间，让你目不暇接。
Plus puzzles and a pub quiz, The Rest Is History Return, available now in all good bookshops. Way Hannibal in the scales, how many pounds will that peerless general mark up today? This is the man, for whom Africa was too small a continent, though it stretched from the surf-beaten ocean shores of Morocco east to the steamy Nile, to Ethiopian tribesmen and the uncharted habitats of elephants. Now Spain swells his empire, now he surmounts the Pyrenees. Nature throws in his path, high alpine passes, blizzards of snow. But he splits the very rocks asunder, moves mountains with vinegar. Now Italy is his, yet still he drives himself on. So that was the Roman poet Juvenal and he wrote a satire on the vanity
此外还有各种谜题和酒吧智力测验。《The Rest Is History Return》现已在各大优质书店上架。在天平上称量汉尼拔，今天这位无可匹敌的统帅能博得多少分量？这就是那个觉得非洲大陆都嫌太小的男人，尽管它西起摩洛哥海浪拍打的海岸，东至蒸汽弥漫的尼罗河流域、埃塞俄比亚部落以及大象未知的栖息地。如今，西班牙使他的帝国扩张，如今他跨越了庇里牛斯山脉。大自然在他的征途上布满高耸的阿尔卑斯山口和漫天暴风雪。但他却将坚硬的岩石劈裂，用醋来搬移大山。如今意大利已属于他，然而他仍然鞭策自己不断向前。刚刚那是罗马诗人尤维纳利斯，他写过一首讽刺人类虚妄愿望的讽刺诗
of human wishes. So a classic case of hubris followed by nemesis. We actually heard a version of that, didn't we Tom, a few weeks ago when we did our series about Peter the Great and the rise of Russia. So that was Dr. Johnson that we heard from in 1748. And he was turning juveniles Latin into English and updating the characters. So it was all about Charles the 12th. That's right. Yes. So juvenile there in that passage, very famous, describes Hannibal
所以这是一个典型的傲慢招致毁灭的案例。汤姆，其实我们几周前在做关于彼得大帝与俄罗斯崛起的系列节目时，就听到过类似的版本，对吧？我们听到的那是1748年的约翰逊博士。他把尤维纳利斯的拉丁文翻译成英文，并赋予了现代色彩。所以讲的其实是查理十二世的故事。没错。是的。所以尤维纳利斯在那段文字中，非常著名地描述了汉尼拔
crossing the Alps, dissolving boulders and rock with vinegar, invading Italy, but in the long run, he will lose the war to the Romans and end up a defeated fugitive. And Dr. Johnson, in his updating of it, his equivalent of Hannibal was, as you said, Charles XII, the heroic king of Sweden, whose career followed a very similar trajectory to Hannibal's. The greatest general of his age but ultimately defeated by Peter the Great. So on one level, you know, an excellent parallel and a parallel that I hope our listeners will enjoy. However, on another level, I think it doesn't work at all because essentially there are very few people except perhaps you and the Swedes who really really remember Charles XII,
翻越阿尔卑斯山，用醋溶解巨石，入侵意大利，但从长远来看，他将输给罗马人，并最终沦为一个战败的逃亡者。而约翰逊博士在对其进行现代化改写时，他笔下的“汉尼拔”对应人物，正如你所说，就是瑞典的英雄国王查理十二世，他的生平轨迹与汉尼拔极其相似。他是他那个时代最伟大的统帅，但最终被彼得大帝击败。所以从某种层面上讲，这是一个极佳的平行对比，我也希望我们的听众会喜欢这个对比。然而，从另一个层面来看，我觉得这完全行不通，因为基本上除了你和瑞典人之外，几乎没有人真正、真正地记得查理十二世了，
but Hannibal is one of the great brand names of history. So we've already mentioned Vin Diesel, Denzel Washington, they both want to play him, Ian Botham, the great England cricketer who crossed the Alps with an elephant for a charity walk. And that thing of Botham doing his charity walk with an elephant, it's pinpointing the single most famous thing about Hannibal, which is the episode highlighted by Juvenal, which is that he crosses the Alps. And even though Juvenal doesn't mention it, he crosses the Alps with elephants. And I would say, I mean, wouldn't you?
但汉尼拔却是历史上最伟大的金字招牌之一。所以我们之前已经提到过范·迪塞尔、丹泽尔·华盛顿，他们都想扮演他；还有伊恩·博瑟姆，这位伟大的英格兰板球运动员，曾带着一头大象翻越阿尔卑斯山来进行慈善徒步。博瑟姆带着大象进行慈善徒步这件事，恰恰击中了关于汉尼拔最著名的一点，也就是尤维纳利斯重点提到的情节，那就是他翻越了阿尔卑斯山。而且尽管尤维纳利斯没有提及，他是带着大象翻越阿尔卑斯山的。而且我想说，难道你不会这么认为吗？
It's not just probably the most famous scene in ancient history. It's one of the most famous scene in ancient history. It's one of the most famous scenes in all of history. Definitely. I can remember having a children's book when I was seven. I can picture where I was when I read this book, where I was in Mrs. Mason's classroom and the illustrations showing Hannibal crossing the Alps with the elephants. They stuck in my mind forever because it's the incongruity of it. And the sort of lurid, extraordinary, colorfulness of this episode. Who would dare to do this to take on the Romans?
这不仅可能是古代历史中最著名的场景，它也是整个历史中最著名的场景之一。绝对是的。我还记得我七岁时有一本儿童读物。我能清晰地回想起我读这本书时的情景，当时我在梅森夫人的教室里，插图上画着汉尼拔带着大象翻越阿尔卑斯山。它们永远留在了我的脑海里，因为这种场景极其荒诞，
March all the way with elephants over the Alps. An incredible scene. Yeah. And so that is what we're going to be looking at today. We will be asking why Hannibal wanted to invade Italy, why he chose to take his army with his elephants and everything across the Alps. I mean, is it the obvious way to go? And you know, is it a brilliant stratagem or is it a disaster? So that's what we'll be finding out today. But before we do that, Tom, remind us where we got to last time. So we ended last time in remind us where we got to last time. So we ended last time in 218 BC on a cliffhanger because after years, months of gathering tension, Carthage and Rome are once again at war. And
并且带有这种离奇、非凡、色彩斑斓的戏剧性。谁敢这样做，去挑战罗马人？带着大象一路翻越阿尔卑斯山行军。这是一场令人难以置信的场景。是的。所以这就是我们今天要探讨的内容。我们要探讨为什么汉尼拔想要入侵意大利，为什么他选择带着军队和大象等一切装备翻越阿尔卑斯山。我的意思是，这是显而易见的路线吗？你知道，这究竟是一个高明的策略还是一场灾难？这就是我们今天要揭晓的答案。但在我们这样做之前，汤姆，提醒一下我们上次讲到哪里了。所以我们上次结束时，提醒一下我们上次讲到哪里了。所以我们上次结束时，
the trigger was the city in Spain called Saguntum, which Hannibal as the commander of the Carthage unions in Spain had taken and sacked and the Romans had gone ballistic, hadn't they? Yes. So Hannibal would say this city is within the area of Spain that the Romans have agreed should be Carthaginian and the Romans say yes, but Saguntum is an exception because it was an ally of ours and Hannibal has now sacked it. A Roman embassy goes to Carthage to complain to demand that Hannibal be handed over to them and the Carthaginians refuse. And so the Romans declare war and the Carthaginians say, fine, if you want war, then let's go for it. And the obvious point to make about that is that you don't opt for war unless you think you can win it. So the fact that both sides are happy to return to this Titanic conflict,
时间定格在公元前218年，留下了一个悬念，因为在经历了数年乃至数月的紧张局势蓄积之后，迦太基和罗马再次开战了。而导火索是西班牙的一座城市，名叫萨古通姆。汉尼拔作为迦太基人在西班牙的军队统帅，攻占并洗劫了这座城市，这让罗马人气急败坏，对吧？是的。所以汉尼拔会说，这座城市位于罗马人同意应当属于迦太基的西班牙领地范围内；而罗马人则说，是的，但萨古通姆是个例外，因为它是我们的盟友，而汉尼拔现在把它洗劫了。罗马使团前往迦太基进行交涉，要求将汉尼拔交出来，但迦太基人拒绝了。于是罗马人宣战，而迦太基人则表示，好啊，如果你们想要战争，那就来吧。对此，一个显而易见的观点是，除非你认为自己能赢，否则你是不会选择开战的。因此，既然双方都乐意重燃这场世纪大战，
both sides think, yeah, you know, we can win this. So we should probably just look at the two sides to kind of work out why first the Romans and then the Carthaginians think that they're going to emerge triumphant from it. So the Romans first, it's important to emphasize that to a degree that is exceptional, even by the standards of ancient states in the Mediterranean, they love a war. I mean, there's a sense that war is the purpose of the Roman Republic. They are used to winning, they expect to win, and they are looking forward when they declare war on Carthage to the consequent profits. And this combines with a sense, kind of almost a mafiosi sense, that they should never accept being disrespected. And I think if you think of the Roman Republic as a kind of massive extortion racket, you're not so
双方都认为“是的，我们能赢”。所以我们或许应该审视一下交战双方，以弄清楚为什么首先是罗马人，然后是迦太基人，都认为自己将在这场战争中获得胜利。首先来看罗马人，必须要强调的是，在某种程度上这是极其罕见的，即便以地中海古代国家的标准来看也是如此：他们太热爱战争了。我的意思是，有一种感觉，战争就是罗马共和国的目之所在。他们习惯了胜利，他们期望胜利，当他们对迦太基宣战时，他们正翘首以盼随之而来的利益。这与一种心态相结合，几乎是一种黑手党式的心态，即他们绝不接受被蔑视。我想，如果你把罗马共和国看作是一个庞大的敲诈勒借集团，你其实并
far removed from the truth. So to quote Simon Hornblough, a very distinguished scholar of antiquity in his wonderful book Hannibal and Scipio, modern analysis suggests that the cause of the change attitude towards Carthage was that the Roman officer class needed fresh outlets and theatres for aggression now that control of peninsula Italy was secure So essentially the Republic depends on the oiling of their wheels with money with cash with loot And that's why so many of them are prepared to say yes Let's go to war with Carthage, even though you know, the costs may be Enormous and one reason why they're so keen to do this presumably, you said they think they can win.
没有偏离真相太远。借用古代史杰出学者西蒙·霍恩布劳在其精彩著作《汉尼拔与西庇阿》中的话：“现代分析表明，（罗马）对待迦太基态度的改变，其原因在于，随着意大利半岛控制权的稳固，罗马军官阶层需要新的侵略出口和舞台。”因此，从根本上讲，共和国的运转离不开金钱、现金和战利品的润滑。这就是为什么他们当中有那么多的人准备齐声说：“好，让我们对迦太基开战吧”，尽管你知道，代价可能是巨大的。他们之所以如此热衷于此的一个原因，推测正如你所说，他们认为自己能赢。
I mean, they've got very good reasons that they can win because they have arguably the single most effective and most ruthless killing machine in the ancient world, which is their Roman infantry, right? Well, they definitely have the most formidable infantry. And it's formidable because it's the expression of a highly militarized civic society. A legion, a legio, is the levy of the entire mass of male Roman citizens. And these legions are highly drilled, well armed. They have immense esprit de corps. They go into battle pretty confident that they're going to win.
我的意思是，他们有非常充分的理由相信自己能赢，因为他们拥有古代世界可以说是最有效率、最冷酷无情的杀戮机器，也就是他们的罗马步兵，对吧？嗯，他们的确拥有最令人生畏的步兵。而且它之所以令人生畏，是因为它是高度军事化公民社会的体现。一个军团（legio），就是全体成年罗马公民的征召兵。这些军团训练有素、武装精良。他们具有极高的团队精神。他们投入战斗时，满怀着定能取胜的信心。
So very high morale, they're very, very intimidating and frightening. But on top of that, there are just, you know, there are loads of them. The Romans have huge reserves of manpower. And the reason for that is the way that their empire has kind of emerged because the Romans are very generous to defeated enemies who acknowledge their defeat in the way that a mafia boss is generous to the shopkeeper who hands over a proportion of his takings. They are offered protection. So some of the cities in Italy who've been defeated, some are enrolled as Roman citizens, which obviously then swells the numbers of men who can serve in the legions. Others are granted kind of associate forms of citizenship, which again accrue kind of benefits. So the number of citizens that the Romans command are not just the people who
因此，他们的士气非常高昂，极其威严且令人畏惧。但除此之外，他们的数量也非常庞大。罗马人拥有庞大的人力储备。原因在于他们的帝国崛起的方式，因为罗马人对待那些承认失败的战败敌人非常慷慨，就像黑手党老大对待交出部分收益的小店主那样慷慨。他们向其提供保护。因此，意大利一些被征战击败的城市，一部分被纳为罗马公民，这显然壮大了能够在军团中服役的男丁数量。另一些则被授予了某种准公民身份，这同样能带来种种好处。因此，罗马人能够掌控的公民不仅居住在罗马城内，他们越来越多地分散在意大利各地的殖民地和同盟城市中。更多的公民显然意味着更庞大的军队，更庞大的军队意味着更多的征服，而更多的征服又意味着更多的公民。这是一个非常、非常良性的循环。因此，步兵非常、非常精锐。但是，当然，罗马的力量现在增添了一个以前并不存在的维度，那就是他们在海上击败了迦太基。因此，他们基本上掌控了海上航道，这在以前从未有过。迦太基传统的海上霸权在第一次布匿战争中就已经被罗马摧毁了。而且还要记住，罗马人不仅勒索控制了西西里岛——这是罗马任何进攻非洲和迦太基行动的显而易见的发兵基地，他们还夺取了萨丁尼亚岛和科西嘉岛，
live in Rome, they're increasingly scattered in colonies and allied cities across Italy. And more citizens obviously means larger armies, and larger armies mean more conquests, and more conquests mean more citizens. So it's a very, very virtuous circle. So infantry, very, very proficient. But of course, there's now an added dimension to Roman power, which hadn't previously existed, which is that they've defeated Carthage at sea. So essentially they have control of the shipping lanes, which had never happened before. Carthage's traditional naval supremacy had been destroyed in the first great war with Rome. And remember also that the Romans have extorted control not just of Sicily, which is the obvious launch pad for any Roman invasion of Africa and Carthage, but they've also taken Sardinia and Corsica,
而这两个岛屿正是通往西班牙的跳板。因此，罗马的战略实际上非常明显。这是一场双管齐下的进攻。你将军团调往西西里岛，在那里他们可以对迦太基构成潜在威胁；同时你拥有萨丁尼亚岛和科西嘉岛，它们可以用来对西班牙的汉尼拔发起进攻。所以是双管齐下的战略，这就需要两位统帅。这就是罗马宪政发挥作用的地方，因为罗马是一个共和国。没有了在公元前506年被驱逐的君主，
which are the stepping stones to Spain. So the Roman strategy effectively is pretty obvious. It's a two pronged attack. You move legions to Sicily where they can potentially threaten Carthage, and you have Sardinia, you have Corsica, they can be used to launch attacks on Hannibal in Spain. So kind of two pronged, and that requires two commanders. And this is where the Roman constitution kicks in because Rome is a republic. And instead of a monarch, which had been kicked out in 506 BC, there
现在有了两位国家元首。国王的权力被分给两位行政长官，每人选举任职一年，这些长官就是执政官。拥有这两位执政官——这两位在和平时期以及战争时期都主持大局的当选领袖，绝对极其完美地契合了罗马的军事目的。公元前218年，第一位执政官是一个名叫提比略·塞姆普罗尼乌斯·隆格斯的家伙，他被派往南部的西西里岛。他拥有24,000名步兵、2,400名骑兵、160艘军舰。这对于海峡对岸的迦太基来说构成了极大的威胁。这就是他在公元前218年夏天所做的事情。他基本上在筹备入侵非洲。然后是第二位执政官，一个名叫普布利乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·
are now two heads of state. So the powers of the king divided up between two magistrates, each one elected for a year and these magistrates are the consuls. And to have these two consuls, these two elected leaders who officiate in peace, but also in war, obviously suits Rome's military purposes absolutely ideally. And in 218, the first consul is a guy called Tiberius Sempronius Longus, and he is sent south to Sicily. He has 24,000 infantry, he has 2,400 cavalry, he has 160 warships. This is very, very menacing for Carthage across the Straits from Sicily. And so this is what he's doing in the summer of 218. He is preparing essentially to invade Africa. Then there's a second consul, a guy called Publius Cornelius
西庇阿的家伙，他被赋予了对付汉尼拔并可能对西班牙发起入侵的职责。所以他正在为此做准备，但随后意大利北部又爆发了一场高卢人的起义。高卢人居住在阿尔卑斯山两侧，一直是一个极具威胁的敌人。他们最近刚刚被罗马人安抚，但他们不喜欢罗马人的枷锁，想要摆脱它，于是在公元前218年头几个月发生了一场叛乱。西庇阿成功击败了高卢人，随后他着手组建一支远征军，规模几乎与塞姆普罗尼乌斯在西西里岛的军队一样庞大。因此西庇阿拥有22,000名步兵、2,200名骑兵、60艘船，但他向西前往西班牙的出发时间被延迟了，直到8月才出发。不过，你有一种确切的感觉：罗马战争机器的齿轮
Scipio, and he is given responsibility for handling Hannibal and potentially launching an invasion of Spain. So he's preparing for that, but then there is another Gallic uprising in northern Italy, the Gauls, who are either side of the Alps and have always been a very menacing foe. They've just recently been pacified by the Romans, but they don't like the Roman yoke, want to throw it off, and there is a rebellion in the early months of 218. Scipio manages to defeat the Gauls and he then sets about raising an expeditionary force that is almost as large as Sempronius is down in Sicily. So Scipio has 22,000 infantry, 2,200 cavalry, 60 ships, but he is delayed in setting off westwards towards Spain and he doesn't leave until August. But you have a definite sense that the wheels of this Roman war machine
在这里真正开始运转了，这个国家是多么令人敬畏。所以，不管有没有延迟，当你列举所有这些事情时，罗马将会取胜似乎是不可避免的。他们拥有步兵的陆上力量、海上力量、无与伦比的人力，他们拥有公民文化的资源，他们军事化的公民文化比任何其他可比国家都要强大。面对这一切，当你审视这一切时，听众可能很可能会想：他怎么会如此鲁莽，竟然敢去对抗这个——正如历史将证明的那样——这个时代的超级大国？
are really starting to grind here of just how intimidating a state it is. So delay or no delay, when you list all those things, it seems inevitable that Rome will win. They have the land power of their infantry, they have sea power, they have unparalleled manpower, they have the kind of resources of their civic culture, their militarized civic culture, which is more formidable than that of any other comparable state. So against all that, when you look at all that, you might well say listeners may well be thinking, why would he be so reckless as to take on what is clearly this as history will demonstrate the superpower of the age?
我想部分原因是他不想给罗马人在西班牙留下突破口。部分原因是他不想给罗马人在西班牙留下突破口，是因为西班牙是他的力量和他的城市力量的关键。它为他提供了矿产财富。正如罗马人所熟知的那样，战争的命脉是黄金。汉尼拔拥有大量的贵金属。他可能拥有整个地中海地区训练最精素、最具实战经验的军队。你知道，他把它磨练得炉火纯青。他磨练的另一件事是他自己作为将领的能力，他从小就在马背上度过。基本上他在押注自己。所以他真心认为这一切足以抵消罗马人拥有的制度优势。是的，因为他有自己的战略，这是一个
I think partly because he doesn't want to give the Romans an opening in Spain. And partly the reason he doesn't want to give the Romans an opening in Spain is because Spain is the key to his power and to his city's power. So it has provided him with mineral riches. And as the Romans famously know the sinews of war are gold. Hannibal has lots of precious metal. He has probably the most highly trained, the most battle seasoned army anywhere in the Mediterranean. You know, he's absolutely honed it. The other thing he has honed is his own capacities as a general, which he has been in the saddle since childhood. And basically he's backing himself. So he genuinely thinks all this is enough to outweigh the institutional advantages that Rome has. Yes, because he has a strategy and this is a strategy
我认为显然由他自己、由他的父亲哈米尔卡以及西班牙所有的军官团共同成型的战略，他们反思了迦太基在第一次布匿战争中战败的原因。他们显然已经搞清楚了问题所在，并且意识到罗马军事成功的关键——无论遭受多少次失败仍能继续坚持的原因——正是她依赖于对意大利控制而拥有的大量人力储备。而阻止并斩断这个“九头蛇”头颅的唯一方法，如果你愿意这么说的话，就是说服意大利那些与罗马结盟的各州和城市放弃同盟，摆脱对罗马的从属地位。而汉尼拔能够做到这一点的唯一可能途径，就是在最痛的地方打击
that I think has clearly been informed by himself, by his father Hamilcar, by all the officer corps in Spain reflecting on the reasons for Carthage's defeat in the first Punic War. They've obviously worked out what the issue is, and they have realized that the key to Rome's military success, the reason that she can grind on no matter how many defeats she suffers, is these incredible reserves of manpower, which are dependent on her control of Italy. And the only way to stop and cut off the Hydra's head, if you like, is to persuade the states and the cities in Italy that are allied to Rome to abandon their alliance, to throw off their subordination to Rome. And the only way that Hannibal has any prospect of doing that is to attack
罗马人，也就是意大利本土本身。这是迦太基人在第一次布匿战争中没有做过、甚至没有想过去做的事情。这是一个比迦太基人以往尝试过的任何事情都要大胆得多的战略。当然，这样做另一个好处是，如果汉尼拔能够成功入侵意大利，那么它就会转移罗马人的注意力，使他们无法入侵西班牙，更关键的是无法入侵非洲。因为即使汉尼拔击败了罗马对西班牙的入侵，他也无法
the Romans where it will hurt, namely in Italy itself, which the Carthaginians had not done or even thought to do in the first Punic war. It's a strategy that is immediately bolder than anything that the Carthaginians have attempted before. And of course, the other benefit of it is that if Hannibal is able to launch a successful invasion of Italy, then it will distract the Romans from invading Spain and crucially Africa. Because even if Hannibal defeats the Roman invasion of Spain, he won't be able
阻止罗马人入侵非洲、封锁迦太基并可能将其逼入战败的境地。所以我想他已经认定这是他能够取胜的唯一途径。但显而易见的是，这引发了一个巨大的难题：既然罗马控制了海域并占领了科西嘉岛和萨丁尼亚岛，他究竟要怎么前往意大利呢？因为汉尼拔用船只将部队运送到意大利是不安全的。所以他必须走陆路。
to stop the Romans from invading Africa and blockading Carthage and possibly kind of bringing her to defeat. So I think he, he settled on this as being the only way that he can win. But obviously that's raised a massive problem, which is how is he actually going to get to Italy when Rome controls the seas and has occupied Corsica and Sardinia, because it's not going to be safe for Hannibal to ferry his troops on ships to Italy. So he's got to travel by land.
所以现在我们正在逼近阿尔卑斯山和大象的问题，因为如果他走陆路，他就必须穿过高卢。他必须穿过庇里牛斯山脉顶部，穿过高卢，然后再折返穿过阿尔卑斯山进入意大利。这就引发了高卢的问题，对吧？它位于他在西班牙的领地与罗马在意大利的帝国之间。高卢部落支持谁？他们是独立的，对吧？他们没有向哪一方效忠。嗯，意大利北部有一些高卢人已经被罗马人征服了。
So now we're approaching the issue of the Alps and the elephants, because if he's going by land, he's going to have to go through Gaul. He's going to have to go across the top of the Pyrenees through Gaul and then back down across the Alps into Italy. So this raises the issue of Gaul, right, which is in between his possession, the Carthaginian possessions in Spain and the Roman Empire in Italy. Who do the Gallic tribes support? They're independent, right? They're not pledged to one side or the other. Well, there are some Gauls in Northern Italy who have been conquered by the Romans. And
显然高卢人能看清形势。他们知道罗马人极具扩张性。所以他们感到紧张。于是汉尼拔想，嗯，这里有文章可做。于是在公元前218年初，他派遣特使去与各个部落谈判，说：“听着，你们能给我提供安全通道吗？我和你们是一边的。
obviously the Gauls can read the runes. They know that the Romans are very expansionist. So they're nervous. And so Hannibal thinks, well, there's something here to play with. And so he sends ambassadors early in 218 to negotiate with the various tribes and say, look, can you give me safe passage? I'm on your side.
我要帮你们击败罗马人。”随后他的一些代理人回来报告说：“是的，高卢人对此很感兴趣，你知道的，不同的部落——并非全部，但有些部落——会向你提供帮助。”他们一直在四处散发金银，试图以此确保通行的安全。与此同时，汉尼拔在罗马有间谍，所以他随时掌握着那里的各种动向。这反映出一个事实：对意大利发起陆路入侵显然是一场巨大的豪赌。在没有获得所有能够收集到的情报之前，他是不愿轻举妄动的。为了获取这些情报，他付出了巨大的努力。而这再次
I'm gonna help defeat the Romans. And a number of his agents do come back and say, yes, the Gauls are kind of interested in this, you know, various tribes, not all of them, but various tribes will offer you help. And they've been scattering, you know, gold and silver to try and facilitate safety of passage. And at the same time, Hannibal has spies in Rome, so he's keeping track of the kind of the various developments there. And this reflects the fact that obviously launching a land invasion of Italy is clearly a massive gamble. And he's reluctant to do it without all the information that he can get. And he goes to great lengths to get that information. And this again,
将成为他战略的一个主题。这也是为什么罗马历史学家（后来的李维就是典型代表）基本上会说他作弊的原因，因为他总能掌握情报。你知道，他有一种近乎超自然的洞察力，能知道发生了什么。罗马人认为这基本上是不公平的。我不认为这真的是作弊，我认为这只是优秀的情报工作，但暂且不论这个。他肯定知道这是一场巨大的豪赌，对吧？他把一切都押上了，押上了他在西班牙建立的所有势力。如果他要通过高卢对意大利发动这次进攻，你知道，
will be a theme of his strategy. And it's one of the reasons why Roman historians, which Livy is the exemplar later, will basically say he cheats because he's always on top of information. You know, he has this kind of almost supernatural ability to know what is going on. And the Romans see this as basically not being fair, really. I don't think that's really cheating. I think that's just good intelligence, but that's by the by. And he must know that this is a massive gamble, right? He's staking everything, all his, the power that he's built up in Spain. If he's going to launch this attack on Italy through Gaul, you know,
事情可能会对极其糟糕。确实如此。因此，不仅要争取尽可能多的中立部落倒戈至关重要，同样重要的是，他需要得到神的庇佑。正如我们在上一集中提到的，李维指控汉尼拔不敬神明、对神明不屑一顾、对他们顶撞蔑视。我的意思是，这完全不是真的。事实上，李维本人就记录了一个非常重大的关于汉尼拔随时准备向神明表示敬意的例子。因为他写道，萨古通姆陷落后不久，大概在公元前218年春天，汉尼拔
it could go horribly wrong for him. It could. And so not only is it important to get as many kind of neutral tribes to come over to him as possible, but just as importantly, he needs the backing of the gods. So we mentioned in the previous episode, Livy's accusation against Hannibal that he disrespects the gods, he has no time for them, that he scorns them. I mean, this is absolutely not true at all. And in fact, Livy himself records a very momentous example of Hannibal's readiness to show respect to the gods, because he writes about how soon after the fall of Saguntum, so probably in the spring of 218, Hannibal
对他的所有部队进行了一次大阅兵。随后，引用李维的话，“他前往加代斯（也就是加的斯），在那里向提尔的赫拉克勒斯履行还愿，并为这次冒险的持续成功发下了更多的誓愿。”所以提尔的赫拉克勒斯是一位名叫梅尔卡特的正神。加代斯是最古老的腓尼基定居点之一，所以梅尔卡特是从如今的黎巴嫩境内的提尔被带到那里的神明。梅尔卡特是提尔的神圣保护神，同时也是汉尼拔家族的保护神。他大概是在春天去的，这是一个梅尔卡特——有点像耶稣——理应从
stages a great review of all his troops. And then having done that, quote Livy, he went to Gardez, which is Cadiz, there to discharge his vows to the Tyrian Hercules and bound himself with further vows for the continued success of his venture. So the Tyrian Hercules is a god called Melkart. Gardez is one of the oldest Phoenician settlements, so Melkart is a god who's been brought there from Tyre in what's now Lebanon. Melkart is the divine patron of Tyre, but also of Hannibal's dynasty. And he probably goes there in the spring, which is a time when Melkart, a bit like Jesus, is supposed to have risen from
死里复活的时期。因此，这种伟大的英雄复活的意象，以及迦太基重返其在西地中海古代霸权的平行对照，是非常、非常显而易见的。但汉尼拔想要将自己与梅尔卡特联系起来并获得梅尔卡特支持的另一个原因，是因为这具有巨大的宣传价值，不仅对迦太基人如此，对罗马人和更广泛的希腊世界也是如此，因为梅尔卡特在地中海各地被普遍认为是希腊英雄中最著名、最令人生畏的一位，即赫拉克勒斯。也就是那个带着棍棒和狮皮的大力士。当然，赫拉克勒斯是一个伟大的怪物斩杀者。这就是他的职责所在。他游历世界斩杀怪物。
the dead. So it's this idea of the great hero coming back to life and the parallels with Carthage returning to her ancient hegemony in the Western Mediterranean is kind of very, very obvious. But there's a further reason why Hannibal would have wanted to identify himself with Melchart and to get Melchart's backing is because there's enormous propaganda value, not just for the Carthaginians, but for the Romans and for the broader Greek world, because Melchart, across the Mediterranean, is universally identified with perhaps the most famous and formidable of all the Greek heroes, who is Hercules. So the strong man with the club and the lion skin. And of course, Hercules is a great slayer of monsters. That's what he does. He roams the world killing monsters.
根据希腊神话，他的其中一次冒险曾将他一路从希腊带到了大西洋。这就是为什么直布罗陀海峡被希腊人称为“赫拉克勒斯之柱”。赫拉克勒斯被认为在那里竖起了石柱。然后从赫拉克勒斯之柱出发，他穿过西班牙，穿过庇里牛斯山脉，穿过高卢南部，翻越阿尔卑斯山，来到意大利，
And one of these adventures, according to Greek mythology, had brought him all the way from Greece to the Atlantic. And this is why the Straits of Gibraltar are known to the Greeks as the Pillars of Hercules. Hercules is meant to have set up pillars there. And then from the Pillars of Hercules, he travels back through Spain, across the Pyrenees, through southern Gaul, over the Alps, and he comes down into Italy
并统治了意大利人，征服了意大利。所以你可以看出，为什么这种由古代英雄开辟的“赫拉克勒斯之路”——他从西班牙出发前往意大利并成为伟大征服者——的理念，会让汉尼拔想要将自己与之联系起来。我认为，尽管我们没有迦太基的直接宣传，但在李维的著作中有一个支离破碎的故事，能让我们大致了解汉尼拔可能如何利用这些故事和神话。所以李维书中的故事是：汉尼拔从加代斯回来，他在那里向梅尔卡特（也就是赫拉克勒斯）献祭，然后他率领军队沿着赫拉克勒斯之路从新
and imposes himself on the Italians and conquers Italy. So you can see why this idea of there being a road of Hercules taken by an ancient hero who travels from Spain to Italy and is a great conqueror. You can see why Hannibal would want to identify himself with that. And I think that although we don't have Carthaginian direct propaganda, there is a garbled story in Livy that enables you to kind of get a handle on what Hannibal might have been doing with these kind of stories and myths. So the story in Livy is that Hannibal is coming back from Gardez where he's been making sacrifice to Melchart, aka Hercules, and he's leading his army along the road of Hercules from New
迦太基向埃布罗河（迦太基西班牙的边界）进发。接着他做了一个梦。在这个梦里，他看到一个神态庄严的男子，声称自己是被众神之王朱庇特派遣而来，指引汉尼拔前往意大利的。这个神一般的人告诉汉尼拔：“不要回头看”，但汉尼拔情不自禁地回了头。他看到身后有一条体型惊人的巨蛇在滑行，对树木和灌木造成了巨大的破坏，其身后还伴随着震耳欲聋的雷雨。
Carthage up towards the Ebro, which is the frontier of Carthaginian Spain. And then he has a dream. In this dream, he saw a man of godlike appearance who claimed he had been sent by Jupiter, the king of the gods, to guide Hannibal to Italy. And this godlike man tells Hannibal, don't look behind you, but Hannibal can't help himself. And he sees behind him a snake of an amazing size sliding along and causing massive destruction to trees and bushes, a deafening thunderstorm following in its wake.
汉尼拔询问那个年轻人这个怪物般的幻象是什么，这个预兆意味着什么。他被告知那是对意大利的毁灭，他应该继续他的旅程，不要再问更多问题，让命运笼罩在黑暗中。人们可能会想，这到底是怎么一回事？理查德·迈尔斯有一篇精彩的文章，我认为他令人信服地证明了，这个故事起源于汉尼拔和他的宣传人员，那个未命名的超自然向导——在梦中出现在汉尼拔面前的年轻人——就是赫拉克勒斯，而他看到的怪物就是九头蛇，九头蛇有许多巨大的脖子，你砍掉一个脖子，另一个又长出来。这非常像
Hannibal asked the young man what the monstrous apparition was and what the portent meant. He was informed that it was the destruction of Italy and that he should simply proceed on his journey, asking no further questions and leaving destiny shrouded in darkness. And people may be wondering, well, you know, what on earth is all this about? There's a brilliant essay by Richard Miles who demonstrates, I think conclusively, that the story originated with Hannibal and his propagandists and that the unnamed supernatural guide, this young man who appears to Hannibal in the dream is Hercules and that the monster that he sees is the Hydra and the Hydra has these great necks, you cut off the neck and another one grows back. And it's very like
罗马军团。事实上，伊庇鲁斯国王皮洛士——他曾入侵意大利，并将大象引入罗马人和迦太基人的视野中，也就是第一次布匿战争爆发几十年之前——曾明确地将罗马共和国比作九头蛇。我认为汉尼拔和他的宣传人员正在利用这一点做文章。汉尼拔被告知：你将杀死九头蛇，你将能够砍掉它的所有脖子，它将变成一截流血的树桩。好吧，通过这种宣传，你可以感受到汉尼拔的使命，他的这种思想意识事业。但我们对后勤也有所了解，对吧？也就是他认为自己能够取胜的那种实力。
the Roman legions. And in fact, Pyrrhus, the king of Epirus, who had invaded Italy and introduced the Romans and the Carthaginians to elephants, so a few decades before the first Punic War, he had explicitly compared the Roman Republic to the Hydra. And I think Hannibal and his propagandists are making kind of play with that. Hannibal is being told, you will kill the Hydra, you will be able to cut off all its necks and it will become just a kind of bleeding stump. Okay, so with that kind of propaganda, you get a sense of Hannibal's mission, his kind of ideological enterprise. But we also have some sense of the logistics, don't we? The kind of muscle
因为几十年后，希腊历史学家波利比乌斯看到了一块碑文，上面记载了汉尼拔带来的人数：90,000名步兵、12,000名骑兵和37头大象。因此，这在古代世界的标准看来是一支相当强大的军队，非常、非常强大的军队。而这就是随同他一起出征的迦太基军事精英中的精锐，对吧？是的。所以这些人，他们大多数其实并不是迦太基人。
with which he thinks he can win. Because some decades later, a Greek historian, Polybius, saw a tablet on which it was written how many troops Hannibal had brought with him. 90,000 infantry, 12,000 cavalry, and 37 elephants. So this is a pretty formidable force by, I mean, a very formidable force by the standards of the ancient world. And this is the sort of the, this is the cream of the kind of Carthaginian military elite who are traveling with him, right? Yes. So these men, most of them are not actually Carthaginians.
正如你所说，最高级别的军官是迦太基人，他们对汉尼拔非常忠诚。他们在与汉尼拔并肩作战中历经战火锻造。他们一直受到汉尼拔和汉尼拔前任们的鼓励，要展现主动性，展现独立行动的能力。我认为，这其中传承了汉尼拔早期作为骑兵指挥官的遗风，强调通过脖颈来抓住时机，并在机遇出现时紧紧抓住。我想，其中最著名的军官是一个名叫马哈巴尔的人。在萨古通姆围城战中，汉尼拔大腿受伤后，他曾代行其职。他可能是汉尼拔的侄子。他似乎与巴卡家族有姻亲关系（如果还没有成婚的话），他将证明自己和汉尼拔一样是一位伟大的骑兵指挥官。
As you said, the highest ranking officers are, they're very loyal to Hannibal. They've been battle forged by serving alongside him. They've been encouraged by Hannibal and by Hannibal's predecessors, always to show initiative, always to show independence of action. There's a legacy there, I think, of Hannibal's early record as a cavalry commander, you know, an emphasis on seizing the moment by the scruff of the neck and always taking opportunities where they arise. And I guess the most celebrated of these officers is a man called Mahabal, who at the siege of Surguntum after Hannibal got wounded in the thigh, he deputized for him. He may have been Hannibal's nephew. He seems to have kind of, if not maybe
汉尼拔的小弟弟马戈也是如此，他像汉尼拔一样，被父亲培养成了一名极其优秀的军事统帅。所以，这就像亚历山大身边的年轻军官核心圈子一样。汉尼拔的军官们经历过极其残酷的战火考验。我的意思是，正如时间将证明的那样，他们非常、非常高效。但是，汉尼拔军队的主力，并不是像罗马那样由公民组成的军队。他们大体上要么是从当地土著中强征的人，比如来自非洲的利比亚人、来自西班牙的伊比利亚人，要么就是雇佣兵。因此非常、非常多元文化。按照传统，
married into the barked family, and he will prove himself a very great cavalry commander like Hannibal himself. And so too will Hannibal's youngest brother, Mago, who like Hannibal has been raised by his father to be a very, very proficient military operator. So again, it's like the cadre of young men around Alexander. Hannibal's officers are incredibly battle-hardened. I mean, very, very effective as time will prove. But the mass of Hannibal's army, these are not as Rome's is a kind of citizen army. They are by and large either people conscripted from native peoples, so Libyans from Africa, Iberians from Spain, or mercenaries. So very, very multicultural. And traditionally,
——我总是记得我小时候读过的关于这方面的书——这被认为是一个真正的问题。迦太基军队充斥着各种不同的语言，不像罗马人那样都说同一种语言并拥有共同的公民理想。但我认为很明显，实际上汉尼拔军队多元文化的特质反而帮了他。从某种意义上说，多样性就是它的力量，因为它的组合要丰富得多。而且由于他从西地中海各个地方征召的各种部队，每个人都有自己擅长的专长。
I mean I always remember the books I read about this as a child, that this was cast as a real problem. That the Carthaginian army was a babel of different tongues, unlike the Romans who all spoke the same language and shared the same civic ideals. But I think it's pretty clear that actually the multicultural quality of Hannibal's army is actually, it helps him. Diversity is its strength in that sense, because it's so much more varied. And because all the various troops that he's recording from the various elements of the Western Mediterranean, they each have specializations.
例如，伊比利亚步兵以其剑术闻名。最终，罗马人实际上也采用了西班牙剑——短剑（gladius），这是一种用于刺入、剖开内脏的刺剑。伊比利亚人还拥有“法尔卡塔”（Falcata）弯刀，这是一种优雅的弧形刀，用于砍劈和突刺。所以这是非常、巴厘岛的剑士队伍。
So the Iberian infantry, for instance, very famed for their swordsmanship. And the Romans actually, in the long run, will adopt the Spanish sword, the gladius, stabbing sword, used to eviscerate, cut open the guts. The Iberians also have the Falcata, which is a kind of elegant curved sword used for cutting and again for thrusting. So very, very fearsome bodies of swordsmen.
然后是巴利阿里群岛的投石手。当我还是个孩子的时候，我对巴利阿里群岛的投石手着迷不已。我就是喜欢“巴利阿里”这个词。我想对很多听众来说，巴利阿里会让人联想到伊比沙岛和夜店之类的东西。可能不包括你，多米尼克。然后是来自北非努米底亚的骑兵，大概是柏柏尔人吧。所以他们住在今天的摩洛哥、阿尔及利亚一带。
Then you have the Balearic slingers. And when I was a child, I was obsessed by Balearic slingers. I just loved the word Balearic. And I guess for lots of people listening, Balearic will kind of sum up images of Bitha and clubs and things. Probably not you Dominic. And then you have cavalry from Numidia in North Africa, kind of Berbers, I guess. So they live in what today would be Morocco, Algeria.
他们基本上就像蒙古人一样，生活在马背上。人们注意到他们不使用马勒或嚼子，而是骑无鞍马，但他们几乎就像半人马一样，就那样生活在他们的马背上。这些绝对是世界上最好的轻骑兵。所以那里有令人难以置信的丰富多样性，比罗马人所能调动的军事力量要杂得多。当然，最著名的莫过于汉尼拔的远征军拥有大象。我们提到过，希腊国王皮洛士是如何将它们带到
And they essentially, a bit like the Mongols, live on horseback. And it was noted of them that they use no bridle or bit and rode bareback, but they almost like centaurs, they just kind of live on their horses. And these are easily the best like cavalry in the world. So you have incredible variety there, much more varied military forces than the Romans can command. And of course, most famously of all, Hannibal's expedition has elephants. And we mentioned how Pyrrhus, the king of the Pyrrhus, the Greek king, had brought them
意大利的，但他受到了亚历山大的启发，亚历山大在印度见过大象。他在与波鲁斯作战时……当他在与波鲁斯作战时，是的。自那以后，大象成为了任何一个注重自我形象的希腊军阀都想拥有的最时髦的东西。我想原因在于它们如此强烈地表现出绝对的力量。它们能带来恐怖。如果你是一个步兵站在那里，有一头巨大的大象朝你冲过来。我的意思是，这是令人窒息的。所以如果你像希腊将军和国王那样有着庞大的野心，你就能明白为什么大象是这种野心的完美化身。关于这一点，有趣的是，
over to Italy, but he's inspired by the example of Alexander who had met them in India. He had when he was fighting Porus. When he's fighting Porus, yes. And since that time, elephants have become the most fashionable thing that any self-respecting kind of Greek warlord would want. I think the reason for that is that they are so expressive of sheer power. They terrorize. You're an infantry man standing there, you have a massive great elephant rushing at you. I mean, it's overwhelming. And so if you have kind of gargantuan ambitions as Greek generals and kings tend to you can see why an elephant is the perfect embodiment of that. And on that it's interesting
罗马作为一个共和国，其实从未真正使用过大象。这似乎与他们的战术不太契合，但迦太基人确实使用了大象，因为他们的军队更加多元化。你采用一点这个，采用一点那个。他们至少从公元前260年代起就开始使用大象了。所以到了汉尼拔的时代，他们已经非常习惯于在战术上部署它们了。他们知道如何使用它们。人们可能会好奇，这些大象来自哪里？汉尼拔的远征军中肯定有一头大象来自印度，因为它的名字叫居鲁士。
that Rome, which is a Republic, never really, they never employ elephants. It doesn't really seem to have meshed with their tactics, but the Carthaginians do use them because their armies are much more kind of mix and match. You take a bit of this, you take a bit of that. And they have been using them since at least the 260s BC. So by Hannibal's time, they're pretty used to, you know, deploying them tactically. They know how they can be used. And people may be wondering, where do these elephants come from? There is certainly one elephant in Hannibal's expedition that comes from India because he is called Cyrus.
它只有一根象牙，显然是个狠角色，名字叫居鲁士，意思是叙利亚人，显然是因为它来自东方，最终来自印度。但汉尼拔随行的绝大多数大象似乎都是从阿特拉斯山脉、摩洛哥海岸带过来的。显然现在那里已经没有大象了，它们已经灭绝了。但当时那里有相当多的数量。
He has one tusk, apparently kind of a real bruiser and he's called Cyrus, which means the Syrian, obviously, because he's come from the East, so ultimately from India. But most of the elephants in Hannibal's train seem to have been brought from the Atlas mountains, from the coast of Morocco. And they obviously there were no elephants there now, they've gone extinct. But back then there were quite a lot.
它们当时是本地的，不是从撒哈拉以南运过来的。对，所以它们来自北非。它们比印度大象略小一些。肩高大约八英尺，而不是九英尺。与居鲁士不同——你可以给居鲁士绑上像城堡一样的结构，就像“大象与城堡”地名那样，你可以在大象背上建一座城堡，就像《王者归来》里那些巨大的大象一样。大象。我的意思是，它们没有那么大。但汉尼拔能够骑在居鲁士身上，
They were native back then, they're not brought from across the Sahara. No, so they're from North Africa. And they're slightly smaller than the Indian elephants. So eight feet tall rather than nine feet tall. And they unlike Cyrus where you can strap it, so like the elephant and castle, you can put a castle on the back, like in return of the king, those massive elephants. An elephant. I mean, they're not quite as big as that. But Hannibal is able to ride on Cyrus, you
你知道的，因为你可以在居鲁士背上放一座大城堡，但你不能把它们放在较小的北非大象背上。所以从某种意义上说，大象本身就是塔楼。它们有点像坦克，我想。再次，我认为汉尼拔之所以如此热衷于带上它们，是为了宣传目的，也是为了纯粹的军事目的，因为这表达了一种神圣的野心。
know, because you can put a kind of great castle on Cyrus's back, but you can't put them on the backs of the smaller North African elephants. So in a sense, the elephants themselves are the towers. They are kind of great. They're like tanks, I suppose. And again, I think one of the reasons why Hannibal is so keen to take them is for the propagandistic purposes as well as the purely military ones, because it's expressive of kind of a divine ambition. I
我的意思是，谁会想到带着大象穿过庇里牛斯山脉、穿过阿尔卑斯山？我的意思是，这闻所未闻。嗯，赫拉克勒斯会这么做。这就是他会做的那种事。是的。所以汉尼拔既想让人敬畏，又想让人震惊，我想。所以问题来了，汤姆，他真的能做到吗？赫拉克勒斯曾经做到过，但他毕竟是宙斯的儿子。他确实是，是的。汉尼拔只是哈米尔卡·巴卡的儿子。所以最大的问题是，他真的能把所有这些大象、所有的军队、
mean, who would think of taking elephants across the Pyrenees, across the Alps? I mean, you know, unheard of. Well, Hercules would. That's the kind of thing he would do. Yes. So Hannibal wants to, he wants to, to awe as well as shock, I think. So the question, Tom, can he actually do it? Now Hercules had done it, but he was the son of Zeus. He was, yes. Hannibal is only the son of Hamilcar Barker. So the big question is, can he actually get all these elephants and all of these troops
所有的投石手、带着女人的人们以及那些拿着精美宝剑的人全部带过去吗？他能把他们带过高卢，带上阿尔卑斯山，然后再从另一侧带下来吗？这是整个历史上最非凡的壮举之一。中场休息之后，我们将揭晓他究竟有没有做到这一点。GMC卡车月火热进行中。驾驶2025款西拉1500 Pro Graphite皮卡，以低至0%的融资利率（最长可达72个月），带着满满的自信纵情驰骋在开阔的道路上。配备可选的5.3升V8发动机、20英寸高光黑色喷漆铝合金轮毂、带有可选2英寸工厂安装升高套件的越野悬挂，以及高达13,200磅的牵引能力，在这个卡车月，你将准备好应对任何挑战。卡车月现正火热进行中。详情请咨询您的GMC经销商
and all of these slingers paid with women and these people with their elaborate swords. Can he get them across school, up into the Alps and down again the other side? It's one of the most extraordinary enterprises in all history. And after the break, we will find out whether or not he does it. It's Truck Month at GMC. Tackle the open road with added confidence in a 2025 Sierra 1500 Pro Graphite at 0% financing for up to 72 months. With an available 5.3 liter V8 engine, 20 inch high gloss black painted aluminum wheels, off-road suspension with available 2 inch factory installed lift kit, plus a towing capacity of up to 13,200 pounds, you'll be ready for anything this Truck Month. Truck Month is on now. Ask your GMC dealer
所有这些投石手都用女人支付报酬，还有那些带着精美宝剑的人。他能带他们穿过学校，上到阿尔卑斯山，然后再下到另一边吗？这是整个历史上最非凡的壮举之一。休息之后，我们将拭目以待他是否能成功。GMC卡车月来了。驾驶2025款Sierra 1500 Pro Graphite开启开放之路，更加自信，享受0%利率长达72个月的分期。拥有可选的5.3升V8发动机、20英寸高光黑喷漆铝合金轮毂、配备可选2英寸原厂升高套件的越野悬挂，以及高达13,200磅的牵引能力，这个卡车月你将应对一切挑战。卡车月正在进行中。请咨询您的GMC经销商
for details. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So we're in the late summer of 218 BC. Hannibal has set off from Spain across the Pyrenees with this mighty army and he has crossed into Gaul and Tom, by the time the summer is nearing its end, he is halfway to Italy. But by this point he's already started to lose a lot of his men, hasn't he? What's going on? Why are they falling away? Yeah, so it's estimated by ancient sources and I think they're generally held to be pretty reliable. So the 90,000 who had infantry who'd left new Carthage, about 50,000 remain. And of the 12,000 cavalry, about 9,000 remain.
欲知详情。欢迎回到《剩余皆历史》。我们正处于公元前218年的夏末。汉尼拔率领着这支庞大的军队从西班牙出发，翻越比利牛斯山，进入了高卢。汤姆，当夏天接近尾声时，他已经走到了去往意大利的一半路程。但到这个时候，他已经开始损失大量部下了，对吧？这是怎么回事？他们为什么会掉队？是的，根据古代史料的估计，我认为它们通常被认为是相当可靠的。因此，离开新迦太基时那9万名步兵，大约还剩下5万名。而在1万2千名骑兵中，大约还剩下9000名。
And the reason for that is that the going has been quite tough. So Carthage's rule extends to the Ebro, but from the Ebro up to the Pyrenees is, you know, it's quite a tough journey. So they've got to defeat people along their way. There's obviously casualties, then you need to set up garrisons. There have probably also been desertions, you know, if there are people from Iberia who don't particularly want to go, they can just kind of melt away. And this is kind of potentially alarming, not just because the numbers have been depleted, but also because as you said, it's now kind
原因在于这一路的行程相当艰难。迦太基的统治范围延伸到埃布罗河，但从埃布罗河到比利牛斯山，你知道的，这是一段相当艰难的旅程。所以他们必须在途中击败当地人。显然会有伤亡，然后你需要建立驻军。可能还会有逃兵，你知道的，如果有些来自伊比利亚的人不是特别想去，他们就会直接溜走。这可能令人担忧，不仅是因为人数减少了，还因为正如你所说，现在的时间
of later than Hannibal would ideally want. It's a kind of invading, you know, Russia in early September kind of thing. Probably not what you want to be doing. However, the reason that Hannibal carries on isn't just kind of mad recklessness. It's because he still has confidence in his ability to execute his plan. The forces that he has with him now, those who have not deserted, those who have not been kind of set up to secure his communication links with Spain, these are the best of the best. These are absolutely committed and loyal to him. And so he says, let's go for it. So he's crossed the Pyrenees. He's now into into southern Gaul, southern France, and there are two immediate challenges
比汉尼拔理想中的要晚。这就有点像在9月初入侵俄罗斯那种情况。可能不是你想做的事。然而，汉尼拔继续前进的原因不仅仅是疯狂的鲁莽。而是因为他依然对执行自己计划的能力充满信心。他现在身边的军队，那些没有逃跑的，那些没有被派去确保他与西班牙通讯联络的部队，是精锐中的精锐。他们绝对忠诚于他，对他也坚定不移。所以他说，我们冲吧。因此，他翻越了比利牛斯山。他现在进入了南高卢，也就是法国南部，这里有两个迫在眉睫的挑战
confronting him. The first is where are the Romans? So what's happened to Scipio? Scipio has got his legions, he's got his cavalry, he's got his ships. Hannibal knows that he'll be sailing westwards. Will he be going to Sardinia? Will he be going to Spain? Will he be going to South Gaul? What's he going to be doing? No news of him as yet. Then there's the other issue, which is how do you cross the river Rhone, which is massive? There are no bridges. It's a real problem.
摆在眼前。第一个是罗马人在哪里？西庇阿怎么了？西庇阿有他的军团，有他的骑兵，有他的战舰。汉尼拔知道他会向西航行。他是会去萨丁尼亚？还是去西班牙？还是去南高卢？他到底要做什么？目前还没有他的消息。然后是另一个问题，那就是如何穿过宽阔无比的罗讷河？这里没有桥梁。这是一个真正的问题。
It's a very, very broad river. And its lower reaches are controlled by the Greek city of Massilia. So this is what will become Marseille. And Massilia is an ally of Rome. And so Hannibal can't rely on the Massilians to allow him to use their bridges. So he has to go up river to find a
这是一条非常非常宽的河流。它的下游由希腊城市马西利亚控制。这就是后来的马赛。而马西利亚是罗马的盟友。因此汉尼拔无法指望马西利亚人允许他使用他们的桥梁。所以他必须逆流而上去寻找一个
suitable crossing point. And this is very difficult because it's the land around the lower reaches of the Rhône, it's a combination of marsh and scrub, so not pleasant at all. So they keep going up the river Rhône for four days from the sea and finally he arrives at a place where he thinks, yeah, this might be possible, we could probably make a crossing here. And it's probably near the site of what a century later will be the Roman foundation of Arles. Very handsome city. Fantastic amphitheatre. Yes. So very, very Roman, but there's nothing there at this point. And it's still pretty tricky because the river is still very wide, the current
合适的过河点。这非常困难，因为罗讷河下游周边的土地是沼泽和灌木丛的结合体，一点也不舒适。于是他们沿着罗讷河从海里逆流而上走了四天，终于到达了一个他认为“对，这里可能行得通，我们大概可以在这里过河”的地方。这里可能靠近一个世纪后罗马建立的阿尔勒的遗址。非常美丽的城市。奇妙的露天剧场。是的。所以非常非常罗马化，但此时那里什么也没有。而且情况依然相当棘手，因为河面仍然很宽，水流
is quite swift. And worst of all, on the opposite side, there is a Gallic tribe called the Volcae, who have not pocketed Hannibal's gold, or if they have pocketed Hannibal's gold, they have betrayed their promise that they will give him a safe crossing and they have massed along the far bank and are determined not to give the Carthaginians a welcome at all when they make the crossing. So these are real challenges and we have fortunately what is probably an eyewitness account, probably from the Spartan Sossilus who was accompanying Hannibal on his trip and if it is Sossilus he writes, Hannibal used every resource to make friends
相当湍急。最糟糕的是，在对岸有一个叫沃尔卡的盖尔部落，他们没有收下汉尼拔的金子，或者即使他们收下了汉尼拔的金子，他们也背叛了保证让他安全过河的承诺，并在远岸集结起来，当迦太基人过河时，他们决心绝不给对方好脸色。所以这些都是真正的挑战，幸运的是我们有一份很可能是目击者的记载，很可能是随汉尼拔同行的斯巴达人索西卢斯写的，如果是索西卢斯，他写道，汉尼拔用尽一切资源与住在岸边的当地人交好，
with the natives living by the bank, and he bought up all their canoes and boats, of which there were a large number, since many of the inhabitants of the Rhone Valley are engaged in seaborne trade. He also obtained from them the kind of logs which are suitable for building canoes so that within two days he had mustered an innumerable quantity of small ferry boats. And you can see there that on this side of the bank, clearly his gold and his agents have worked because he's, he's being provided with the way with all to get across the river, but he's still got this problem of the Volcae. How's you going to deal with them?
他买下了他们所有的独木舟和小船，数量非常庞大，因为罗讷河谷的许多居民都从事海上贸易。他还从他们那里弄到了适合建造独木舟的圆木，于是在两天之内他就聚集了数不清的小渡船。你可以看到，在这一边的岸上，显然他的金子和特工起作用了，因为他得到了过河的工具，但他仍然面临着沃尔卡人的问题。他要怎么对付他们？
So he waits five days past since he's arrived on the bank, the Volcae lined up on the far bank. And then on the morning of the sixth day, Hannibal standing on the bank, the Volcae lined up on the far bank, and then on the morning of the sixth day Hannibal standing on the bank and he's looking upriver and he sees rising from there, from a point upriver, a plume of smoke. And this is clearly a signal because he then gives orders for his troops to start making the crossing. And again to quote this eyewitness, the large boats were placed the furthest upstream and directly against the current and the lighter ones below them so that the heavier craft should absorb the main force of the water and the canoes be less exposed to risk in crossing. So very, very kind of sensible. And the horses have to swim on either side of the large boats with a man on each side kind of keeping
所以他等了五天，自从他到达岸边以来，沃尔卡人在对岸排好阵势。然后在第六天早晨，汉尼拔站在岸上，沃尔卡人在远岸列阵，然后在第六天早晨汉尼拔站在岸上，他向河的上游望去，看到从那里，从上游的一个地方升起了一缕青烟。这显然是一个信号，因为他随后下令部队开始渡河。再次引用这位目击者的描述，大船被放置在最上游且直接迎着水流，较小的船只则放在它们下方，以便较重的船只吸收水流的主要冲击力，让独木舟在过河时受到的风险减小。这非常非常明智。马匹必须在大船的两侧游泳，每侧都有一个人抓着
hold of the reins to stop them from kind of being swept away on the currents. And it's all very exciting. The boats are racing each other. There's kind of lots of cheering, lots of military banter, Dominic. Right. Love it. And meanwhile, of course, the Volcae are waiting. So very, very tense. What is going to happen when the prowess of the Carthaginian boats and canoes start crunching up against the gravel of the far shore. Yeah, exciting. Very exciting. Well, what happens is a stunning twist of the kind that will increasingly come to be associated with Hannibal's campaigns.
缰绳，防止它们被水流冲走。这一切都非常令人兴奋。船只在互相竞速。有许多欢呼声，许多军事上的打趣，多米尼克。没错。太棒了。与此同时，沃尔卡人当然在等待。所以气氛非常非常紧张。当迦太基船只和独木舟的船头开始发出驶上远岸砂砾的嘎吱声时，会发生什么呢？是的，令人兴奋。非常令人兴奋。嗯，发生的事情是一个惊人的反转，这种反转后来会越来越多地与汉尼拔的战役联系在一起。
Because just as the Carthaginian vessels start landing on the far bank, the Volcae are alarmed to hear on their right flank, a sudden pounding of hooves and wild Numidian war cries. Because what Hannibal has done is he has sent his Numidian cavalry, the best light cavalry in the world upriver to make a secret crossing higher up. Because of course they can gallop up there, make the crossing and then gallop back down. And that plume of smoke that he'd seen was the signal that the Numidians were ready to pounce.
因为就在迦太基船只开始在远岸登陆时，沃尔卡人惊恐地听到他们的右翼突然传来了密集的马蹄声和野蛮的努米底亚战吼。因为汉尼拔所做的是，他派出了世界上最好的轻骑兵——努米底亚骑兵，逆流而上去更高处进行秘密渡河。因为他们当然可以骑马到那里，完成渡河然后再骑马赶回下游。他看到的那缕青烟就是努米底亚人准备发起进攻的信号。
And the Volcae are taken completely by surprise. Their camp is burnt. They they they run away. The Carthaginian army is able to make to forge a bridgehead and the men are able to get across. And you know how good I am on bridges. A bridge is going too far and all that kind of thing. Here, there's no need for a bridge because they've got
沃尔卡人完全被打了个措手不及。他们的营地被烧毁了。他们逃跑了。迦太基军队得以建立一个桥头堡，士兵们得以过河。你知道我对桥梁有多拿手。造桥就有点太过分了诸如此类的话。在这里，根本不需要桥，因为他们有
rafts and boats and things. There is of course one final challenge, which is how do you get an elephant onto a boat? Not something I've ever really contemplated, but how do you do it? I'm curious. Well, you build a succession of massive rafts and you then lash them together and you kind of push them out into the river and then you cover them with earth so that they seem to just be part of the river bank so that the elephants don't realise as they're being led from the bank onto the rafts that
木筏、小船之类的东西。当然还有一个最后的挑战，那就是如何把大象弄到船上？这不是我真正考虑过的事情，但你到底怎么做？我很好奇。嗯，你建造一连串巨大的木筏，然后把它们绑在一起，把它们推到河里，接着在上面铺上泥土，让它们看起来就像是河岸的一部分，这样大象从岸上被引导到木筏上时就不会意识到
they're moving onto something that is floating on the river. And then having done that, you get them onto the kind of the far rafts, you cut the moorings, the rafts start going across the river and the elephants at this point, they panic, but they're calmed by their mahouts, the guys who steer them. And some of these are thrown off into the river and they drown, which is very sad. The elephants, all 34 of them, they make it across. That's good news because no one really cares about the mahouts, but everybody cares about the elephants. Of course. So this is great drama. They've made their way across the Rhone. That's another
它们正在移动到浮在河上的东西上。完成这些之后，你把它们弄到远处的木筏上，砍断系缆，木筏开始横渡河流，大象在这个时候惊慌失措，但它们被驯象员——那些引导它们的家伙安抚了下来。其中一些被甩进河里淹死了，这非常令人遗憾。大象，全部34头，都成功过河了。这是个好消息，因为没有人真正在乎驯象员，但每个人都在乎大象。当然。所以这真是太戏剧性了。他们成功横渡了罗讷河。这又是另一个
physical barrier crossed. And then the next day there's further drama because news reaches Hannibal that Scipio and his legions have docked in Massilia in Marseille. And so Hannibal sends a squad of Numidians down the river to Reconnoiter to find out the lay of the land. Scipio has sent a squad of horsemen up the river to find out what Hannibal is doing. The two forces of cavalry meet, the Numidians get the worst of it, but most of them manage to get away. And they come back to Hannibal and say, the Romans are, they're just down the river.
跨越的物理屏障。第二天，更戏剧性的事情发生了，消息传到汉尼拔那里，西庇阿和他的军团已经停泊在马西利亚也就是马赛。于是汉尼拔派出一队努米底亚人顺流而下进行侦察，以摸清地形。西庇阿派出一队骑兵逆流而上，查明汉尼拔在做什么。两支骑兵部队相遇了，努米底亚人吃了亏，但他们大部分都成功逃脱了。他们回到汉尼拔身边说，罗马人，他们就在下游。
What do you want to do? And this is a crucial decision for Hannibal. Does he fight the Romans in Gaul or does he carry on over the Alps? He knows that he outnumbers Scipio. Scipio doesn't have as many troops and also Hannibal would back himself to defeat Scipio, I think.
你想怎么办？这对汉尼拔来说是一个至关重要的决定。他是在高卢与罗马人作战，还是继续翻越阿尔卑斯山？他知道自己在人数上占优势。西庇阿没有那么多军队，而且汉尼拔也自认能够击败西庇阿，我想。
But the danger obviously is that if he fights a battle and it's already getting late in the summer, then it will be very difficult for him having done that to advance into Italy and secure winter quarters before the end of the campaigning season. And he can't risk being stranded in hostile territory that isn't even Italy or winter. I mean, that would be a disaster for him.
但危险显而易见，如果他打一场仗，而且夏天已经快过完了，那么打完仗之后他将很难推进到意大利并在作战季节结束前确保冬营。他冒不起被困在甚至不是意大利的敌对领土上过冬的风险。我的意思是，那对.-他来说将是一场灾难。
What would be so terrible about being in Gaul though? Because Gaul, would he not be the master of Gaul then? No, he wouldn't be the master of Gaul because he's not interested in conquering it. His reason for going to Italy is to get the backing of the subject peoples there to Rome. So he needs to be on the spot, his agents working, getting the Gauls in Northern Italy, hopefully getting some of the cities in lower down Italy, to start moving over to him. Because if that doesn't work, then the whole strategy is not going to work. He can't defeat Rome on his own. He needs to win, get Italian and Gallic backing.
不过，待在高卢到底有什么可怕的呢？因为在高卢，他难道不会成为高卢的主人吗？不，他不会成为高卢的主人，因为他对征服高卢不感兴趣。他去意大利的原因是为了获得那里臣服于罗马的人民的支持。所以他必须亲临现场，通过他的代理人活动，让意大利北部的盖尔人，希望还能让意大利南部的某些城市，开始倒戈向他。因为如果这行不通，整个战略就宣告失败。他无法独自击败罗马。他需要赢得胜利，获得意大利和盖尔人的支持。
So he has to be physically on Italian soil. And so essentially this makes his mind up for him. But what finally I think kind of sways him is that ambassadors come from a Gallic tribe called the Boii who live on the far side of the Alps. So in Italy, who was subject to the Romans, and they're desperate for his support. And this is a really good sign because it suggests that his strategy, you know, has a good prospect of working. And the Boii, these Gallicum envoys, they say, we can show you a way up over the Alps so that you won't have to, you know, go on the Roman roads that skirt the Alps. You'll be able to come down in the Romans
所以他必须双脚踏上意大利的土地。从本质上讲，这为他作出了决定。但我认为最终促使他下定决心的是，来自阿尔卑斯山另一侧的一个名为波伊的盖尔部落的使者来到了。也就是说在意大利，他们曾臣服于罗马，而他们迫切希望得到他的支持。这是一个非常好的迹象，因为它表明他的战略，你知道的，有很大成功的希望。而波伊人，这些盖尔人的特使说，我们可以为你指引一条翻越阿尔卑斯山的道路，这样你就不用走环绕阿尔卑斯山的罗马道路了。你将能够从罗马人的
rear. And of course, this is what Hercules had done. And I think Hannibal recognizes that the propagandistic impact of taking his army, taking his elephants over the Alps, of emerging in the Romans rear is going to be stupefying. And again, this has to be part of his strategy because he has to overwhelm and awe the Italians as well as the Romans. He needs to win them over. So he thinks, yeah, let's go for it. Hell of a risk though, Tom. I mean, hell of a risk. It absolutely is a risk, but he's the heir of Hercules. He's a gambler.
后方突袭而下。当然，这就是海格力斯曾经做过的事。我想汉尼拔意识到，带领他的军队、带着他的大象翻越阿尔卑斯山，从罗马人后方突然出现的宣传效应将是震撼人心的。同样，这必须成为他战略的一部分，因为他必须在气势上压倒意大利人和罗马人。他需要赢得他们的支持。所以他想，好吧，冲吧。但这真是个天大的冒险，汤姆。我的意思是，真是个天大的冒险。这绝对是一个冒险，但他可是海格力斯的传人。他是个赌徒。
But it's not an unreasonable gamble, I think. I mean, it's playing for high stakes, but it's not a wholly mad gamble. And so three days after Scipio's cavalry have had the brush with the Numidians, Scipio himself at the head of his army arrives at the place where Hannibal had crossed the Rhône and he discovers that the Carthaginians have gone. And to quote Polybius, this Greek historian who you mentioned earlier, Scipio was astounded to find that the enemy had already pressed on as he had felt certain that they would never venture to advance into Italy
但这并非不合理的赌博，我认为。我的意思是，这是在下大赌注，但并不是一场完全疯狂的赌博。因此，在西庇阿的骑兵与努米底亚人发生冲突的三天后，西庇阿本人率领军队抵达了汉尼拔过河的地方，他发现迦太基人已经不见了。引用波利比乌斯的话，就是你刚才提到的这位希腊历史学家，西庇阿惊讶地发现敌人已经继续前进了，因为他曾坚信他们绝不敢冒险通过这条路线深入意大利
by this route, partly because of their numbers and partly because of the fickle nature of the barbarians who inhabited the region. However, when he learned that they had taken this risk, he hurried back to his ships and immediately began to embark his forces. So he's gonna take his ships back to Italy so that he will be ready to meet Hannibal when Hannibal comes down from the Alps, if he comes down from the Alps.
部分原因在于他们的人数，部分原因在于居住该地区的蛮族的反复无常。然而，当他得知他们冒了这个险时，他急忙赶回船上，并立即开始让部队登船。所以他要带着船只回意大利，以便准备好在汉尼拔从阿尔卑斯山下来时迎战他，如果他真的从阿尔卑斯山下来的话。
So Hannibal has gone up into the Alps. Now here we come to the kind of question that military historians and people of that ilk spend decades investigating. They really care. You know, it's like the classic thing we said in our 1066 series, which side of the field were they standing on? And some people really care about this. And I think one of the defining things about the rest is history is that ultimately we couldn't care less. What route he takes to the Alps. He goes up into the Alps anyway, and there are all kinds of strange things that people have done, particularly to do with horse manure, that they study to try to work out which way Hannibal went.
所以汉尼拔已经进入了阿尔卑斯山。现在我们遇到了军事历史学家和同类学者们花了几十年时间研究的那类问题。他们真的很在意。你知道的，就像我们在1066系列中说的经典问题，他们当时站在战场哪一边？有些人真的很在乎这个。而我认为“剩余皆历史”的标志性特点之一，归根结底是我们对此漠不关心。他走的是哪条路线去阿尔卑斯山。他反正都是上了阿尔卑斯山，人们做过各种各样奇怪的事情，特别是关于马粪的研究，他们试图借此弄清楚汉尼拔走的是哪条路。
Yeah, so there's a kind of microbe, which is found in horse and, interestingly, elephant manure, and it can survive for thousands of years in soil. So there are scientists going through mountain passes in the Alps, looking basically for elephant shit. Somewhere in the Alps right now, there's a man on his hands and knees desperately trying to find incredibly old horse manure, right? Personally, I don't think it particularly matters which route Hannibal takes, the precise route. And you don't need to know to feel awed by the scale of what he attempts.
是的，有一种微生物，它存在于马的粪便中，有趣的是也存在于大象的粪便中，它可以在土壤中存活数千年。所以有科学家在阿尔卑斯山的山口中穿行，基本上就是在寻找象屎。此时此刻在阿尔卑斯山的某个地方，正有一个人跪在地上，绝望地试图寻找极其古老的马粪，对吧？就我个人而言，我认为汉尼拔走哪条路线并不是特别重要，具体的路线。要对他的壮举规模感到敬畏，你并不需要知道这些。
Right. So when Vin Diesel takes you on as the historical consultant for his film, and you say, oh, it doesn't matter. Yeah, you can do whatever you like. And I think it doesn't matter because it doesn't matter which precisely they are because the basic outline we know we can be fairly confident is accurate because again, I think it derives from eyewitness accounts. And again, chiefly this guy, Sosilis of Sparta, Hannibal's Greek tutor. And they were used by this guy, Polybius, who we've already mentioned, this Greek historian, who is by far the best and most reliable historian of Hannibal's campaigns. And he himself went to the Alps, he tried to trace Hannibal's route. So Polybius by the standards of ancient
所以，当范·迪塞尔聘请你担任他电影的历史顾问时，你说，哦，这没关系。是的，你想怎么拍都行。而且我认为这并不重要，因为具体是哪条路线并不重要，因为我们所了解的基本大纲可以相当有信心地确定它是准确的，因为同样地，我认为它源自目击者的记载。而且主要是这个斯巴达人索西卢斯，汉尼拔的希腊语导师。它们被我们刚才已经提到过的这位希腊历史学家波利比乌斯所采用，他是汉尼拔战役中迄今为止最好、最可靠的历史学家。他本人也去过阿尔卑斯山，他试图追寻汉尼拔的路线。所以按照古代历史的标准，波利比乌斯
history, certainly compared to Livy, is very reliable. And so we will be drawing on Polybius by the standards of ancient history, certainly compared to Livy, is very reliable and so we will be drawing on Polybius' account of Hannibal's crossing the Alps essentially to tell the story of what then happens. So according to Polybius, Hannibal's crossed the Rhône and he continues kind of northwards along its eastern bank. so he's still heading upwards into Gaul. And four days after leaving the crossing point, he arrives in a territory where there's a kind of fratricidal squabble between two brothers who were trying to make themselves king of this tribe. Hannibal backs one of the two brothers,
与李维相比，显然是非常可靠的。因此，我们将借鉴波利比乌斯关于汉尼拔翻越阿尔卑斯山的记载，来讲述接下来发生的故事。根据波利比乌斯的说法，汉尼拔渡过罗讷河后，沿着其东岸继续向北进发。所以他仍然在向上深入高卢。在离开过河点四天后，他抵达了一个领地，那里有两个兄弟为了争夺这个部落的王位而展开了兄弟阋墙的争端。汉尼拔支持其中一个兄弟，
puts him on the throne of the tribe, and wins the gratitude of the victor unsurprisingly and so Hannibal is then able to rest his men to source food to source new weapons to to get alpine clothing you know go to the the alpine shops and get ski gear and all that all that kind of stuff and then having done that he then swings eastwards towards the alps. And it's here that he first runs into trouble because he is now passing into the lands of a very hostile and very aggressive Gallic tribe called the Alabrogues. And to begin with, because the Alabrogues are terrified of the Carthaginian cavalry and elephants, they merely shadow the intruders. So you can
把他扶上了部落王位，毫无意外地赢得了胜利者的感激，于是汉尼拔得以让士兵休息、搜寻食物、搜寻新武器、获取高卢阿尔卑斯山的服装，你知道的，去阿尔卑斯山的商店买滑雪装备之类的一切，做完这些之后，他便向东转向阿尔卑斯山。正是在这里，他遇到了最初的麻烦，因为他现在正穿行于一个非常敌对且极具攻击性的盖尔部落——阿洛布罗ges人的领地。起初，由于阿洛布罗ges人对迦太基骑兵和大象感到恐惧，他们只是尾随着这些入侵者。所以你可以
imagine Hannibal and his men riding along and looking up and seeing shadowy figures of Gallic horsemen up on the heights. But then 10 days into his Eastwards march from the Rhône, they start to climb and ahead of them lie the Alps. And Polybius describes the Alps as seeming to rise above the landscape like a walled citadel above a city. So this sense of mighty natural battlements blocking their path, I mean very, very intimidating. And as they climb following the road, so they find that they're being funneled along a valley. I mean, obviously to climb the Alps, you almost inevitably going to be finding yourself funneling along a valley.
想象汉尼拔和他的士兵们骑马前行，抬头看到高处盖尔骑兵隐约的身影。但随后在他从罗讷河向东进发的第十天，他们开始爬山，前方就是阿尔卑斯山。波利比乌斯将阿尔卑斯山形容为仿佛从大地上拔地而起，犹如城市上方筑有城墙的城堡。这种强大的自然壁垒挡住去路的压迫感，真是非常非常具有威慑力。随着他们沿着道路攀登，他们发现自己被漏斗形的山谷夹在了中间。我的意思是，要翻越阿尔卑斯山，你几乎不可避免地会发现自己被限制在一个山谷里。
And the more it closes in, so obviously the longer Hannibal's line starts to become, because there's less and less space for people to march abreast. So ultimately it's maybe five miles, six miles long. And in due course the valley tapers and Hannibal finds himself at the gateways of what is now a very narrow gorge. And unsurprisingly, he pauses here because narrow gorges and hostile tribesmen are not a good combination. And of course, Hannibal is a great man for intelligence, so he sent scouts ahead of him. And these scouts now come back. And they bring very alarming news, namely that the alabrogues have taken up position along the heights overlooking the gorge because it's a perfect spot for an ambush. And Polybius comments, if the alabrogues had only kept their plan secret, they would have
山谷越收窄，汉尼拔的队伍自然也拉得越长，因为能够并肩行军的空间越来越少。所以最终队伍可能有五英里、六英里长。不久之后山谷变窄了，汉尼拔发现自己来到了如今一个非常狭窄的峡谷入口处。毫无疑问，他在里停了下来，因为狭窄的峡谷和敌对的部族绝不是什么好组合。当然，汉尼拔非常重视情报，所以他派出了侦察兵走在前面。而这些侦察兵现在回来了。他们带来了非常令人担忧的消息，即阿洛布罗ges人已经在俯瞰峡谷的高处占据了有利地形，因为这是设伏的绝佳地点。波利比乌斯评论说，如果阿洛布罗ges人能对他们的计划保密，他们本可以
completely destroyed the Carthaginian army, but they haven't because Hannibal is too good a man at sourcing intelligence for that to happen. Unfortunately, as ever, Hannibal has a stratagem. So as soon as it's dark, he gives orders for masses of campfires to be lit all over the kind of the terrain that the army is occupying to make it as big a show as possible. And so the Alabrogues see this, they assume, okay, well, they've bedded down for the night, we don't need to worry about this. And so they clock off and go back home for the night. Hannibal, meanwhile, has a crack squad of handpicked men. And up they go into the heights and they seize control of the very heights that the Alabrogues had been occupying. And this means that when the Alabrogues come back in the morning, oh no, duh,
彻底消灭迦太基军队，但他们没有做到，因为汉尼拔在搜集情报方面实在太出色了，这种事不可能发生。幸运的是，一如既往，汉尼拔有他的计谋。因此，天一黑，他就下令在军队占领的整个地形上点燃大量的营火，以制造尽可能盛大的声势。于是阿洛布罗ges人看到了这一幕，他们心想，好吧，他们已经扎营过夜了，我们不用担心这个。于是他们便收工回家过夜了。与此同时，汉尼拔拥有一支精挑细选的精锐部队。他们爬上高地，夺取了原本被阿洛布罗ges人占领的高地的控制权。这意味着当阿洛布罗ges人在早晨回来时，哦不，糟了，
we've been tricked by this great general. And obviously, as Polybius says, this means that Hannibal has spared his army from the absolute worst of the ambush that otherwise would have happened. But it doesn't mean that the Carthaginian army is entirely safe because essentially the baggage train is just too tempting.
我们被这位伟大的将领给耍了。显而易见，正如波利比乌斯所说，这意味着汉尼拔让他的军队免于遭受本可能发生的最惨烈的伏击。但这并不意味着迦太基军队绝对安全，因为行李辎重车队实在太诱人了。
And so various warriors start kind of making swoops down, pouncing down and Polybius has a very vivid account of what it was like. He says the road leading up to the pass was not any narrow and uneven but flanked with precipices and so the least movement of disorder in the line caused many of the animals to be forced over the edge with their loads. So these aren't the elephants, it's the mules and also the horses and the pack animals. And Polybius writes that in their fear, they would wheel around and collide with the baggage mules. These are the cavalry horses while others rushing on ahead with thrust aside anything that stood in their way on the narrow path and so through the whole line into disarray. So you're starting to get men falling off
因此，各路战士开始俯冲而下，发动突袭，波利比乌斯对当时的场景有非常生动的描述。他说通往山口的道路不仅狭窄不平，而且两旁都是悬崖峭壁，因此队伍中哪怕出现一丝紊乱，也会导致许多驮着货物的动物连同货物一起被挤下悬崖。这些可不是大象，而是骡子，还有马匹和驮兽。波利比乌斯写道，在恐惧中，它们会转身与行李骡相撞。这些是骑兵的战马，而其他拼命超前的马则在狭窄的路上撞开任何挡路的东西，从而使整支队伍陷入混乱。所以你开始看到有人掉下
the precipice as well. Ah, splat. Is that what the noise they make? That's exactly what it sounded like. Right. But fortunately, Hannibal is up on the heights. He's got his elite squad of hand-picked men. They're able to swoop down and stabilize the situation to inflict slaughter on the, uh, the Alabrogas who are doing the ambush. And so finally, when they emerge from the gorge, the disaster isn't as total as it might have been. And Hannibal is able to lead a
悬崖。啊，啪叽。那是它们发出的声音吗？听起来完全是这样的。没错。但幸运的是，汉尼拔在高地上。他有他精挑细选的精锐部队。他们能够俯冲下来稳定局势，对进行伏击的阿洛布罗ges人进行屠杀。所以最后，当他们走出峡谷时，灾难并没有想象中那么彻底。汉尼拔得以率领
squad of cavalry onwards up the roads and they find the the deserted stronghold of the Alabrogues and it's deserted because they've all gone off to kind of nick, you know, stuff from the Carthaginian baggage train. And here he finds lots of his own men. He finds pack animals who've been taken prisoner and he is able again to boost the number of cattle and crops. And also, you know, there are large storehouses, cattle, crops, all this kind of stuff. So again, he's able to kind of boost his supplies. So it's not all bad. So they rest for a day, then they keep going and they meet another tribe who are a little bit more friendly, who bring them wreaths and stuff. They give him some hostages
一队骑兵继续沿路前进，他们找到了阿洛布罗ges人废弃的据点，之所以废弃是因为他们全都跑去抢夺迦太基辎重车队的东西了。在这里他找到了许多自己的部下。他找到了被俘的驮兽，并且能够再次增加牛群和农作物的数量。而且，你知道的，那里有大型仓库、牛、农作物诸如此类。所以他又能够补充物资了。所以情况并非全然糟糕。于是他们休息了一天，然后继续前进，他们遇到了另一个稍微友好一些的部落，他们给他们送来花环之类的东西。他们送给他一些人质，
and then they keep going for another couple of days and then I mean this is all very reminiscent of Alexander the Great actually marching through Persia through the Zagros mountains and stuff endless kind of gorges and defiles and people waiting for you at the top. Or Cortes in Mexico. Yeah. And once again, there is another ambush prepared. But this time they're going to be attacked from behind, right? The Gauls are going to attack them in the rear. So talk us through that. Yeah. So again, to quote Polybius. So again, he says that if this ambush had been successful, then Hannibal's army would have been
然后他们又继续前行了几天，接着——这其实非常让人想起亚历山大大帝当年行军穿过波斯、穿过扎格罗斯山脉之类的地方，无尽的峡谷和关隘，还有人在山顶等着你。或者像科尔特斯在墨西哥一样。是的。又一次，另一场伏击正在酝酿。但这一次他们将从后面遭到袭击，对吧？高卢人将从后方袭击他们。给我们讲讲这个吧。好的。同样，引用波利比乌斯的话。他再次说，如果这次伏击成功了，那么汉尼拔的军队就会
wiped out. But that Hannibal, you know, he's nervous of what might happen. And so he'd stationed his mule train in his cavalry at the head of the column and he'd put the heavy infantry at the rear. So that means that when the barbarians, the Gauls, attack in the rear, they're not able to plunder, they're met with the stabbing swords of the Spaniards and the spears of the Libyans. And so Polybius writes, the disaster was less serious than it might have been, but even so a great number of men pack animals and horses perished in the attack. And the other thing that enables Hannibal to stabilize the situation is that the elephants come into their own at this point. The ghouls have never
全军覆没。但汉尼拔担心可能会发生什么。所以他把骡队和骑兵安排在纵队的最前面，把重步兵放在了最后。这意味着当野蛮人，也就是高卢人从后方袭击时，他们无法进行掠夺，而是迎头撞上了西班牙人的短剑和利比亚人的长矛。因此波利比乌斯写道，灾难比可能发生的要轻，但即便如此，仍有大量的人员、驮兽和马匹在袭击中丧生。而另一个让汉尼拔得以稳定局势的因素是，大象在这个时候发挥了巨大作用。高卢人从未
seen anything like them. They're much too scared to approach the stretch of the column where the elephants are marching. So actually, the presence of the elephants on this march over the Alps, it redounds to Hannibal's benefit. It does turn out to have been militarily advantageous. And in time, the attacks of these Gallic warriors start to fade away. The sallies by their warriors cease and the boulders that every so often had been kind of rolling down the side of the hill pushed down by the people ambushing the Carthaginians, they stop dropping and the attacks by the natives of the Alps essentially come to an end.
见过这样的东西。他们太害怕了，根本不敢靠近大象行军的那段纵队。事实上，大象在这次翻越阿尔卑斯山的行军中的存在，给汉尼拔带来了好处。它最终被证明在军事上是有利的。随着时间的推移，这些高卢战士的袭击开始逐渐减弱。他们的武士发起的突击停止了，那些每隔一段时间就会从山坡上滚落的巨石——由伏击迦太基人的人推下来的巨石也不再掉落，阿尔卑斯山当地人的袭击基本上结束了。
But clearly this has been a hell of a, you know, Alpine walks go. This has been a horror show. Hannibal's men are in a miserable state. They're shattered. They're demoralized. They've lost friends and it's starting to get cold because it's autumn by now. They've been climbing the Alps for nine days. So the altitude's about 2000 feet. And so it starts to snow. And this is very bad news for Hannibal's men, some of whom may, you know, start getting frostbite, but it's also bad news for the horses and particularly for the elephants, because there's nothing really for them to eat up there. So it's a terrible situation. But then at last, Hannibal is able to say, we have reached the summit.
但很显然，作为一次阿尔卑斯山的徒步之旅，这真是一场噩梦。汉尼拔的士兵们处境悲惨。他们精疲力竭，士气低落。他们失去了战友，而且天开始变冷了，因为现在已经是秋天了。他们已经在阿尔卑斯山上爬了九天。所以海拔大约是2000英尺。于是开始下雪了。这对汉尼拔的士兵来说是个坏消息，他们中的一些人可能开始冻伤，但对于马匹尤其是大象来说也是个坏消息，因为上面根本没有什么东西可以吃。所以这是个可怕的局面。但随后终于，汉尼拔可以宣布，我们到达顶峰了。
And he pitches camp on the summit of the pass and he waits there for two days for all the various stragglers to join him. And they camp out amid the snow, gales screaming all around them. It must have been terrible. But Hannibal is so tough, he doesn't care and obviously sets an example for the rest of his men in a way that Vin Diesel, Denzel Washington, that would do as well. Or Vince Vaughan. Yeah, or Vince Vaughan or indeed Ian Botham. But he knows it's not enough for him just to kind of sleep out in the open like everyone else is. He knows he also needs to pep his men up. And so the way he does this according to Polybius is that
他在山口的顶峰扎营，并在那里等待了两天，直到所有掉队的士兵都赶来会合。他们在雪中露营，狂风在他们周围呼啸。那一定非常可怕。但汉尼拔是如此坚韧，他毫不在乎，并且显然为部下树立了榜样，就像范·迪塞尔、丹泽尔·华盛顿会做的那样。或者文斯·沃恩。是的，或者文斯·沃恩，甚至是伊恩·博瑟姆。但他知道，仅仅像其他人一样露天睡觉是不够的。他知道自己还需要振奋部下的士气。因此，根据波利比乌斯的记载，他做到这一点的方式是
he gathers all his men around him and he gestures out to the Po Valley, Italy, northern Italy, stretching out below him and he says, there it is, Rome awaits us. And there is a problem with this, which actually there isn't a pass from which it's possible to look out from the summit and see Italy. That's terrible pedantry from you, Tom. That's shocking pedantry. When you have your meeting with Vin Diesel, don't say this to him. No, I'm not going to say it. He will want to hear that there is such a pass.
他把所有士兵聚集在自己周围，向下方绵延的波河谷、意大利北部做了一个手势，说，看呐，那就是罗马，在等待着我们。这里有一个问题，实际上并没有哪个山口能够让人从顶峰眺望并看到意大利。汤姆，你这可是严重的学究气啊。这真是令人震惊的学究气。当你和范·迪塞尔开会时，可别这么对他说。不，我才不会说呢。他会希望听到有这样一个山口。
But I think the gist of the story is true. What Hannibal is telling his men is that down there in Italy, we don't have to climb anymore. We can go down now. We have allies waiting to flock to our cause. The lands down there are rich in gold and food and women. And then Polybius tells us he pointed in the direction of Rome itself. So Italy awaits, but obviously there are all kinds of questions still hanging over this expedition. How easy will the descent be? Because often, you know, a descent can be at least as challenging as an ascent. What are the Romans? Where have they gone? What battles will Hannibal face? Will he make it to Rome? And Dominic, how can people find out about that?
但我认为这个故事的核心是真实的。汉尼拔是在告诉他的部下，在那边的意大利，我们不用再爬山了。我们现在可以下山了。有盟友正在等待并投奔我们的事业。那里的土地盛产黄金、食物和女人。然后波利比乌斯告诉我们，他指向了罗马本身的方向。因此意大利在等待着，但显然这次远征仍然悬而未决着各种问题。下山会有多容易？因为通常情况下，下山至少和上山一样具有挑战性。罗马人在哪儿？他们去哪儿了？汉尼拔将面对什么战斗？他能到达罗马吗？多米尼克，人们怎么才能知道这些呢？
Well, there's only one way to have those questions answered and that is to hear the next episode right away. Now the extraordinary innovation that we are pioneering, rolling out, aren't we? Yeah, we're rolling it out, I think it's fair to say, is we've founded a club, would you believe, it's called the Rest is History Club. And the great benefit of this club, well one benefit among many, is that you can hear all the episodes of this series right now. So if you're not already a member of the Rest is History Club, if you're not an early adopter,
嗯，要得到这些问题的答案只有一个方法，那就是立刻收听下一集。现在我们正在开创、推出的非凡创新，不是吗？是的，我们正在推出它，我认为这样说很公平，我们成立了一个俱乐部，你敢信吗，它叫做“剩余皆历史俱乐部”。而这个俱乐部的巨大好处，众多好处之一，就是你可以立刻收听这个系列的所有节目。所以如果你还不是“剩余皆历史俱乐部”的会员，如果你还不是早期尝鲜者，
then you can sign up at therestishistory.com and you can hear right now what happened when Hannibal came out of the Alps, the great battles, the great dramas that followed. If for some peculiar and perverse reason of your own you don't want to join this club, then you can hear what happened on Monday. But why would Earth would you wait? Join the Restless History Club and find out what happened next in the extraordinary story of Hannibal. Bye bye. Bye bye. Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence.
那么你可以在therestishistory.com注册，你现在就能听到汉尼拔走出阿尔卑斯山后发生了什么，随后发生的伟大战役和宏大剧情。如果你出于某种奇特而乖张的个人原因不想加入这个俱乐部，那么你可以在周星期一收听后续。但你为什么要等呢？加入“剩余皆历史俱乐部”，了解汉尼拔传奇故事的接下来发生了什么。再见。再见。嗨，大家好，你们居然还在。在节目快结束时，我对你们的执着深表钦佩。不过听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。
Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what, I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course only one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous
你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗，我希望这个播客的听众听的是关于我品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你这么想过，当然只有一个方法可以知道那会是什么感觉。你可以打断广告的进程。你可以成为下一个汇丰银行卓越理财（HSBC Premier）或在《剩余皆历史》上投放过广告的其他众多强大
companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to Goalhanger.com right now.
公司之一。你可以通过在《剩余皆历史》以及高挂网（Goalhanger Network）的其他节目上投放广告，将你的品牌展示给数百万志同道合的听众。现在你可能会想，我不知道高挂网是什么。高挂网正是打造这个节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你品牌的价值，高挂网非常希望能听到你的声音。你可以立即前往Goalhanger.com登记你的兴趣，或者你公司的兴趣。
And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hanga, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是Goal，拼写为 G-O-A-L，Hanger，拼写为 H-A-N-G-E-R，点com。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。